comment se fait-il que les stadiers et
le brésil l'échappée mais je n'ai pas
fait pire pendant que la france
mais si vous voulez c'est en gros le
même virus certes hier des variants il
ya débutants elle séparera c'est s'aider
gouvernement donc découvert non très
très différents et ont fait un gros
pareil il reste le troisième terme un
dont on parle très peu d'ailleurs en
france dans les commentaires et tous à
savoir les peuples les peuples et c'est
pas très à l'honneur de la france
l'art aux états unis si vous voulez les
décisions sont prises
tenez vous bien au niveau du comté 40e'
un compte et c'est en gros la surface en
moyen d'un département français
il ya 58 compter en californie qui fait
les trois quarts de la france donc c'est
à peu près un département les décisions
qui chaque fois qu'elles sont changés en
france font pousser découvre des cris
d'orfraie qu'est-ce qu'on ouvre
qu'est-ce qu'on ferme laquelle dix ans
peut-on se déplacer hors de son délit
chine de son domicile
les distances entre les gens les fameux
gestes barrières etc
ces décisions sont prises au niveau des
comtés et elle change d'une semaine à
l'autre
notre région en suivant en collant au
plus près à l'évolution du virus
nous on est loin de cela est évidemment
donc même sous trump na li chn un génie
auront en tout cas la californie s'est
mieux comportée
[Musique]